الارباح حوالي 6 مليارات دولار عدد
اللاعبين المسجلين حوالي 400 مليون لاعب
الغرامه 500 وعشرون مليون دولار ارقام
الفلكيه نعم ولكن نعم كلها تتعلق باللعبه
الاكثر شهره على الاطلاق فورتنايت
[موسيقى]
ايبك قيمز الشركه المصنعه للعبه الفيديو
الناجحه ستدفع 275 مليون دولار لحكومه
الولايات المتحده لحل المطالبات التي
تنتهي قانون حمايه خصوصيه الاطفال على
الانترنت من خلال جمع المعلومات الشخصيه
للاطفال دون سن الثلاثه عشر عاما دون
الحصول اولا على موافقه الوالدين
كما ستدفع ابيك مبلغ
245 مليون دولار كما بالغ مسترده
للمستهلكين الذين تضرروا من خيارات
التصميم ما مجموعه
520 مليون دولار كاكبر غرامه تفرضها لجنه
التجاره الفدراليه على الاطلاق
الشكوى المقدمه ضد فورتنايت تناولت
ادعاءات مثل جمع بيانات الاطفال بطريقه
غير قانونيه وتعريض الاطفال للتنمر
والتحرش واسهلت للاطفال شراء العناصر داخل
اللعبه بنقره واحده او الضغط على زر دون
موافقه الوالدين ما ادى الى تقديم اكثر من
مليون شكوى من الاهالي الى ابيك بشان
الرسوم غير المرغوب فيها
الاتفاق بين ابيك ولجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه والذي يستمر 20 عاما سيحضر على
الشركه استخدامه انماط المظلمه او فضل
رسوم على المستخدمين دون موافقتهم كما
طرحت الشركه اصدارا محدودا لفورتنايت
اللاعبين الاصغر سنا يسمح لهم بالدخول الى
بعض الميزات الانتظار الموافقه الوالدين
ولكن هذا يقيد الدردشه والمشتريات لصباح
العربيه
[موسيقى]